honestly the the reason why vladimir
putin is doing this is because democracy
is his enemy we talk about that here a
lot and that i think that ultimately you
know everyone wants to say nato and all
that garbage uh tucker carlson talking
about how nato is the excuse or whatever
the [ __ ] he wants to say the point is is
that vladimir putin vladimir putin not
only hates democracy but he knows it's
his demise and the reason why it's his
demise is because if the russian people
are abreast to what democracy can
deliver them they know that putin will
not deliver them those things they will
not he will not deliver them liberty
jesus christ they banned the word
war
in russia right they banned the word war
forget that they've been going around
russian police officers if if you will
call them that they've been going around
on the streets taking people's phones
and going through their text messages
to see what they've been talking about
if they've been talking about the war in
that way that is
and republicans in america are like oh
the tyrannical government of america
don't buy the socialist regime it's like
dude you can say what you want you can
say your dumbass opinions all you want
on the internet and embarrass yourselves
but you do not see police walking down
the street and grabbing your phone and
looking to make sure that you're not a
dissident yeah at all against the of the
the russian you know the motherland so
well the funny part is is all the people
that are protesting with freedom and you
know all this nonsense they're the ones
like yeah we like putin's a tough guy
that's who we we would want a more
putin-like leader trump trump 2024
trump putin on the chicken
that's what we want we want a trump
putin ticket it just doesn't mean
you're not even lying at all it doesn't
make any sense i wish it made sense
thank you